how you feeling
I feel really good
I can see it I've never been happier
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions even hotter ways and today
we're joined by Jenna Ortega she's a
Golden Globe nominated actor you know
from acclaimed films like X in the
Fallout as well as the massive Global
Netflix hit Wednesday she also stars in
Scream Six the latest chapter in the
iconic slasher franchise which is set to
release in theaters on March 10th Jenna
Ortega welcome to the show thank you for
having me I know that you're a big fan
of hot sauce how confident are you going
into today's interview
I'm feeling pretty confident honestly I
haven't been nervous at all it's only
been within the last 30 minutes that my
friends that are with me today have kind
of been amping me up and I've realized
oh this might be a situation
that I'm not prepared for but typically
I can handle I can handle my stuff so
I'm curious
[Music]
thank you
yeah I am
all right all right
sweet
little baby
baby wing
I do have to tell you too my the gift
for my my father's Christmas gift was
the hot sauce is oh I pledge not to do
any of them because I thought if I ever
go on the show I cannot do it or
whatever but I feel like
I feel like they've I come from a strong
family they've got this they've got
strong taste buds I think we'll be good
so you return for your walls Tara
Carpenter and scream six a franchise
have really come to appreciate for its
meta commentary on the genre where each
film becomes like its own Love Letter to
Classic horror movies of the past what
are the Hallmarks of a good chase scene
for you like when they work on film what
makes them work
oh
um
for a good chasing it's really difficult
I feel like you have to have like uh
you've gotta you gotta have a good
course you know like the the amount of
rooms that you run through I think a
good handheld shot is also really
necessary for a good chase scene because
it makes it feel a lot more chaotic and
a bit more um first person view I feel
like it's a bit more intense for the
audience but
um at least a couple of injuries a
couple of stabs here and there and I
also think a really powerful shot and
one of my favorite things to see in
horror films is when uh you can see your
your heroin your main character and then
you could see the the other villain kind
of in the background I Feel Like
Anything where it's like either they're
not aware that they're there or you get
to see the reaction and the Mayhem going
on behind them I think that that's
always a strong Choice hi
[Music]
thank you
too easy there we go I don't want to get
too confident but at the same time
you gotta gas yourself up as you go you
know
well I feel like around six is when
people start getting weird right so you
just enjoy this time while you got it
you know
so you've gushed about your experience
working with the master of Gothic
fantasy and Tim Burton how did you see
his obsession with aesthetic come
through in the way that he directs
first of all he draws a lot of his shots
so there are some days where I'd come
into work and he would have his own
little picture that he drew of me
playing the cello or me fencing him so
this is what you're shooting you though
got it or um even on the first day when
they were trying to uh establish what my
hair was gonna look like we ran two
hours behind because
um no her braids are on even this one's
lower this one's higher he didn't like
the way that my Fringe looked at the
time so he was just hey can I do you
mind if I do that he has the hairdresser
very politely and just kind of did my
hair himself it would be like four in
the morning and some random Romanian
forest and oh where's Tim and he's
carrying two trees throwing them in the
background of the shot so that they land
exactly where he went he wanted them to
he was very
specific and like happy to do it himself
but also a really great communicator and
collaborator did you come out of the
other side of the Deep dive into his
catalog with a favorite Tim Burton
production hmm
I mean I feel like Beetlejuice is a
state
I have always appreciated Beetlejuice
but I also when I was younger I wanted
to be one of the aliens from Mars
Attacks so bad but not the Lisa Marie
one the one with the exposed braid that
I it he's got Jack Nicholson Glenn Close
in there like it's
an incredible movie I feel like people
don't give it the credit it deserves
wildly underrated movies
all right so far two Wings down are you
ready to move on here to Sauce number
three 100
here all right three spot
[Music]
foreign
that one has more flavor though
is this psychological as well are you
like gonna like feed stuff
in my head so that it you know what I do
a lot of armchair Psychology from this
side of the table yeah yeah we're a lot
of like it's gonna be okay I do a lot of
like I'm a little bit of like
psychologist and like a little bit of a
motivational speaker okay that's my role
from over here I think good to know
and then I understand that your scream
co-star David Arquette is actually a
certified Bob Ross painting instructor
and will sometimes give lessons on set
did you ever have the pleasure of taking
one of those art classes I think I was
actually working when people took that
class which is one of my greatest
um I think I don't there's very few
times where I felt completely defeated
and that is one of them I he is like a
little angel of a person I can't believe
he's real but yeah he gave the entire
cast Bob Ross lessons so we would walk
into our Collective green room and there
would just be beautiful paintings
everywhere but he also had a red
tricycle that he gave us all the code to
so that if we wanted to get our
groceries oh let's just take Dave's
tricycle he was um always hanging out
always like trying to update himself on
Kpop because we had a band member who
really loved K-pop it was
he's an unbelievable man every set needs
a David Arquette you know
agreed it would make things so much
better like there would be no world
peace 100
.
[Music]
all right
that one's actually good
you like that one that's an enjoyable
sauce
[Music]
oh you guys made that yeah I was gonna
say we'll take that we'll take that
Jenna all day long now it's trying to
blow smoke here
so I've had some interesting
conversations with actors in the past
from Tom Holland to Colin Farrell about
the challenges of working from behind a
mask what new tools did you have to
develop and playing a character like
Wednesday whose whole vibe is to be
emotionless when you're
gonna be the the lead of a story you
have to have some sort of emotional Arc
some sort of emotional payoff and
Wednesday doesn't actually have that and
I think that fighting The Nostalgia that
everybody feels for the 60s Wednesday
and 90s Wednesday while also you know
feeding into that but also giving a new
take and and making it your own to a new
generation so that they're introduced to
the character was like a real balancing
act so I found that you know as long as
I studied the old material and took
traits and aspects that I knew I could
easily weave into my own iteration it
felt like a good happy medium
all right Jenna you are doing great this
next sauce halfway mark already by the
way very nice this is Brooklyn Deli
with
the ghost pepper sauce
I'm really trying to take it in
so I think
[Music]
[Laughter]
interesting it has some redeeming
culinary qualities but as you say that
I'm even seeing like I'm starting to
tear up a little bit you know
[Music]
should I follow you as well
it would be like emotional support yeah
yeah listen I'm gonna lean a little bit
on you this okay okay Jenna you know we
can't all that's what I'm here for there
we go I I can tell I'm in good hand I
can't tell I'm in good hands
so in a New York Times interview last
year you talked about not being able to
care for a house plant but spoke very
reverently about protecting your 1897
edition of Ralph Waldo Emerson essays
what for you is the Magic in collecting
books I typically I don't write a lot of
screenplays but I do like to write a lot
of essays I am a bit of an insomniac I
can't really sleep so I just stay up all
night and I write random things that you
know I take a certain thought or or idea
and I just kind of elaborated on on my
own and someone like Emerson a lot of
his work is essays so I feel like the
more that I read and kind of see the
tangents that he goes on or or the
little debates that he has with himself
kind of encourage me to do that but
books are books are incredible I wish
that people would read them more I don't
want to read them on an iPad I
we need real substance like go outside
and read a book
is there a gen Z Trope or stereotype
about teenagers that you see in scripts
or on TV that gets under your skin I
think for me
because I also I I look a bit younger
I've been acting for a little over a
decade now so I've just been a teenager
pretty much in in stories and I feel
like it's always the bratty teen bad
mouth teen or a lot of times
unintelligent which I don't think is
true and I think it's hard to nowadays
with all this new lingo coming around
but I I feel like my generation because
there is so much accessible to them on
the Internet there's just more
opportunities for them to learn
I wish that they were
given a bit more credit we can be smart
sometimes
[Music]
I'm so excited
it actually tastes like mushrooms yeah
it's got some Portobello action in there
whoa
good for them
so I was fascinated to read that thing
wasn't cgi'd but rather played by
Romanian magician Victor dorobantu yeah
what was the most creative or memorable
way that you saw him tap into the
creative depth of that character using
only his hand
oh it actually was that thing operating
room uh scene where um hey they weren't
on him but they were shooting my
coverage and it's the first and only
time Wednesday cries and I
went to like reach my hand out to him
and he pet my hand like he was like
comforting me and I actually started
crying like I restarted the line because
it actually made me sad and we just like
laughed and that was like a real bonding
moment for Victor and I but it kudos to
him because they had him in all kinds of
crazy positions yeah because like in a
whole chroma key suit that they edit out
like later so that's what you think you
think like the hands was there but he's
physically there acting with you yeah
it's there's a blue man in the entire
show and he's just they took him out but
he I remember they would build all these
set pieces for him so they did like um a
wild desk so he was sitting crunched in
a desk or they built Holes in the Floor
um but yeah that was a
a real task I would say and he killed it
[Music]
yeah I'm feeling all right
got it
good flavor
so you called the horror genre your
second home and then once joked I don't
know what it is about my face but people
always want to throw blood on it when
did you know that you'd like to scare
people well I know when I was younger
when people would like jump out behind
walls or something like that I'm
salivating a little yeah
when people would jump out from behind
walls or something like that I never
moved I never flinched and people would
tell me that I have no soul so I felt
like
trying to get them back was kind of the
start of it all I would say from a very
early age
what makes the 80s slasher prom night to
you a gold standard of the genre
oh my God it's got all the classic
teenage tropes it's got incredible Gore
um I feel like there's just so many
Staples that it's inspired so many
horror films to come since then it's
just a proper way to do a slasher like
if you ever needed some sort of Guiding
Light I think prom night is a really
really great great one and then can you
explain the process of what goes into
putting together Prosthetics like this
yeah you go and you get green slime put
all over your body so you sit in a room
for about 30 minutes and they create a
cast like this this rubber cast and then
they send it to some lab they make a
mold of your face and then they just
make a bunch of skin grafts these fake
skin grafts that something like that
takes about four hours to put on they
might add like some some glycerin or
water and then you're pretty much good
to go but that will not move you're good
as long as you don't do something crazy
you're all right
all right Jenna it is that time
this is the bomb Beyond insanity
[Music]
I'll take like a healthy bite as well
because I need the actual experience
[Music]
it's a bit aggressive ah
I think it may have been right to be
scared but look at you just smiling
right in the face of it you know
can you see my White Knuckles there you
go I can see it
and I might start hiccuping I can
already kind of feel it okay just giving
you fear warning
what's the secret to a perfect guacamole
in your opinion
Whole Lotta lime
you need so much lime in there
um and jalapenos
um
just choose good avocados
but lime yeah lime is the answer I hate
it when they throw pico de gallo just on
top like very casually just a couple of
tomatoes it doesn't do anything for me
either fully fully submerged really mix
it in there do it the right way if I
don't see any cilantro in there
disappointing instantly
um and yeah if the avocados are too
white because then you know that it's
going to be hard and they're just not
ready
don't rush them and then in 2015 the New
York Times published a controversial
guacamole recipe well they called for a
ratio of 2 3 cup fresh green peas to
every three avocados
[__] that it's like
it's not even controversial that's
obviously
incorrect
you know if ever I had an episode to
lean on somebody I'm happy it's this
episode because I'm going through it I'm
so sorry if there's anything you need
from me yeah
yes
I'm
it's settling yeah
just in time
to move on to the next wing
this number nine Wing is Taco Vibes only
I have the strength of you have the
strength
this is me leaning Jenna all right
[Music]
yeah
okay
I still really feel just really
vulnerable from
the bomb yeah
never leaves you you know you're forever
changed after something like that I
think so
can you give us one highlight and one
low light from your most recent Paris
Fashion Week
oh
is to be a really big fan of Steve Lacy
when I was younger and still am and he
was there
um I got to meet Gaspar no who is like
an incredible filmmaker and I've really
admired for a really long time I feel
like I was just around like a really
influential group of people
and uh yeah I felt very lucky a low
light
oh I think I've never been up on the
Eiffel Tower and I try to do that and
then they told me no
you got it you got rejected I got the
tower yeah and I walked up the stairs I
did the whole thing and then I was like
okay let me get to the next level and
then they ushered us to like the
elevator going down and we're like just
leave
it's just maybe it just wasn't a good
day I don't know what they went through
all right Jenna Ortega
[Music]
beautiful bottle oh I should shake it
too right
I feel ready
[Music]
what's it good enough that's that's a
that's a good idea that's very good
enough
cheers all right Cheers Cheers
[Music]
that's delicious
that's actually like really good
Jenna I've got the craziest thing on
right now
right back at you right back at you and
look at us taking on the hot ones
Gauntlet living to tell the tale just
one more challenge for you and don't
worry I'm not gonna bring out any more
wings but I was fascinated to learn that
one of the ways that you unlocked the
Wednesday character was when you didn't
take without blinking and then Tim
Burton liked it so much he said hey
let's do every take without blinking so
to close things out what I want to do is
a Stanley Kubrick style stare down
staring contest you versus me to see who
buckles first against this mounting
pressure of the hot sauce and these
bright studio lights are you ready okay
wait let me I'm really stress myself out
all right I feel like that's better that
makes it harder there we go all right
degree of difficulty getting cranked
[Music]
I don't know if I should have done that
okay all right you started okay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm so glad you didn't make that awkward
at the end because that could have been
like a weird way to close it
I thought it was gonna go on for too
long I was like you know what I was
running out of gas but I was really
determined you know I could see I was
reaching the point right there but I
never stood a chance I never stood a
chance yet you're going down my face and
look at you taking out the wings of
death living to tell the tale now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life
um next up I am six installment of the
scream franchise is coming out March
10th I believe and if you want to go
check that out in theaters you can do
that and then also yeah Wednesday is now
streaming on Netflix so
if you want if you don't want that's up
to you
that makes me so happy like what a great
environment
so awesome
that was so cool
here we go
I had a really good time
hot ones fans breaking news the three
and one boneless bites challenge is back
for a limited time you can put your
taste buds to the test against some of
our most iconic flavors the classic Los
Calientes and the peak of heat Apollo
but don't fret hot ones fans even when
the three in one challenge leaves the
freezer aisle you can still pick up your
favorite flavor of hot ones boneless
bites visit hotoneschallenge.com for
more information on products and to find
a store near you because it's time to
bring the Heat home